all right thank you for that shockingly
dark update anything else
yes something I'd like to say a pretty
private person so this is kind of hard
for me but here we go I'm bisexual
alright and well now field one minute
and zero seconds of questions pertaining
to this go Amy how long have you known
since seventh grade I was watching Saved
by the Bell and I thought Zack Morris is
hot and then I thought Lisa turtle also
hot the fact that the words Kelly and
Kapowski didn't just come out of your
mouth is lunacy what made you decide to
tell us now Charles found out on the
road trip and I was positive he was not
gonna be able to keep the secret for
much longer
bye Rosie I mean not by but by I mean
see ya I'm gonna have fun only having
sex with men just beggin dudes left and
right I just stopped saying bye all
together so are you seeing anyone out
yeah her name's Tiffany are you lying
about her name so we won't look her up
yes I am next do you know an Haitian I
do I must say this is going considerably
better than when I came out to my
colleagues they were not as the kids say
awake do you mean woke I did mean woke
but it's grammatically incoherent okay
we have time for one more question don't
know absolutely not we're done smart he
was not chasing Donna this is crazy
typhoon is an artist and the human head
is a canvas just listen you're gonna cut
the man's hair you're gonna charge him
eight dollars it'll take you four
minutes so just shut up
and make the man look like this fine so
typhoon what do you like to do for fun
I'm writing an electronic opera about
Brittany Murphy and I do the shingle
you're design for my friends drag puppet
show no further questions
all I really want to do is dance except
lately all the good warehouse waves are
filled with the Eurotrash Eurotrash I
don't like that it is indeed a garbage
continent yes oh my god I had the worst
time in Berlin last May everyone was on
their stupid bikes that was like ill
please talk more about how you hate
Europe and bicycles Oscar why don't you
take this opportunity to officially come
out
to everybody here however you want to do
it go ahead Sandow I'm doing this for
you yes I'm gay and I didn't plan on
sharing that part of my life with you
today so whatever can I sit down now I'm
not offended by homosexuality in the 60s
I made love to many many women often
outdoors in the mud and the rain and as
possible a man slipped in would be no
way of knowing who should be the judges
and juries of our society judges and
juries yes
that's a good point she is a good point
because gay marriage currently is not
legal under US law I bet a lot of
straight men wish that applied to them
so you could go out there and have some
torrid unabashed monkey sex as much as
they could you know sounds pretty good
right that sounds great yeah Dwight I
think all the other office gays should
identify themselves or I will do it for
them no one else in this office is gay
what about Phyllis she makes absolutely
no attempt to be feminine I'm getting
married to Bob Vance that's great
congratulations Phil as that is great
and frankly kind of amazing ha ha ha ha
see everybody has a chance thank you but
still Phyllis in college
did you ever experiment with other women
a lot of women do No and you knew me in
high school
of course we all thought you were gay in
high school and I take that as a
compliment well with your ties and your
matching rocks I just like to look good
ok
so sound pretty defensive Michael no I
am just coming out myself I am coming
out hetero I think the problem with this
office is that you are sending mixed
signals about my being here no no no the
only signal that I am sending is gay
good look if I was gay I would be the
most flamboyant gay you've ever seen I
would be leading the parade covered in
feathers and just I'd be waving that
rainbow flag I don't think I couldn't
work here any longer this has been the
worst most backwards day of my life you
misunderstand okay all right but you
know what okay okay I uh I'm gonna put
my money where my mouth is
you ready what are you going to embrace
Oscar you might want to watch this
Angela because you can't catch anything
here we go no we are going to make a
statement you and I are going to make a
statement together
Oscar is my friend I'd rather not and I
just don't care who sees it I doesn't
bother me Lee would really rather not
come here Mike Randall no no I don't
want to touch you ever consider that
you're ignorant and insulting and small
okay
all right I'm sorry that was a good idea
come on come on Michael appears to be
gay too
and yet he is my friend I guess I do
have a gay friend no I'm gonna raise the
stakes
you know well you know I want you to
watch this and I want you to burn this
into your brains because this is an
image then I want you people to remember
for a long time to come whenever you
come into the office and want you to
think about this we don't need to yes we
do what
see I'm still here we're all still here
oh come on Dwight come on man what's
going on and we gave night don't worry
and Rochester life time you and I would
have made a hot-ass couple agreed yes
you should be very proud of yourself I
know things aren't exactly where you
want to be right now but I promise you
they will improve Yankee captain
every time someone steps up and says who
they are the world becomes a better more
interesting place so thank you I gotta
hand it to you captain
that was some ceremony but it wasn't
difficult I simply said what I wish had
been said when Kevin and I got married
and I never would have heard your
hilarious
efficient efficient quit the right I
regret nothing
but all this does make me think I might
enjoy a more festive expression of our
commitment to one another
are you suggesting we hold an
honest-to-goodness wedding nothing too
elaborate we're not the Kardashian
West's after all they are musician had a
celebrity personality who recently
wedded me
yes yes I know they were entered on
Jeopardy I think you mean questions you
got to tell me about him I don't know
anything about him okay he's 23 he's
kind of my boyfriend he's gay last year
we got drunk and he took me the Ice
Capades and I didn't get him anything
he's gay yeah Brokeback Mountain DVD no
I always loved that no what does he
already have like chaps like assless
chaps
okay why are you asking me because I
don't know there's no ass to ask really
it's kind of young all right I'll tell
you what I'm gonna think about it do the
course of all day I'm gonna Mull it over
it's all I'm gonna think about but
you're in good hands I'm gonna
was something really really good yeah
all right you got that yeah she's good
she's shot oh hey hey I've been thinking
about your gay boyfriend all day I have
got some awesome ideas first idea
spray-tan gift certificates huh no trip
to Germany Germany is awesome and
expensive good call
I didn't think of that okay you know how
people say that you should give gifts
that you would want to get yourself what
would you want easy Indianapolis Colts
Reggie Wayne Jersey number 87 double XL
home blue signed by Reggie Wayne right
after he catches the touchdown to win
the Super Bowl okay never mind
no Hip Hop Abs dance fitness DVD Oscar
would you reach over and touch his thing
that's what he said right guys cuz of
gay
you